The Revenge of the Obama era judicial
nominees two cases actually three if we
can get to the third that show you just
how certain judges can have an outsize
influence over the policy of this
country the President of the United
States and your lives first a federal
district court judge on Thursday denied
a trump administration request to
dismiss a lawsuit challenging its
decision to add a citizenship question
to the 2020 census a policy by the way
that is completely constitutional
completely sound judge Jessie Furman
from the US District Court for the
Southern District of New York a Barack
Obama appointee said that the
challenger's had successfully proven
that there is quote a heightened risk in
the current political climate of a lower
response rate due to the president's
quote anti-immigrant rhetoric I kid you
not that's not a pundit that's a judge
that's not all a federal judge in
Portland Oregon has ruled that allowing
a transgender high school student in an
Oregon School District to use the boys
locker room and restrooms does not
violate the privacy rights of other
students who may object to sharing that
space US District District Judge Marco
Hernandez you guessed it also an Obama
appointee throughout the lawsuit filed
by parents for privacy they wanted this
group called parents for privacy in
Dallas and saying the ruling if the
parents are upset well they can quote
just remove their children from Dallas
high school if they disapprove of the
transgender student access to these
facilities
well thanks well to discuss this trend
of the politicized judiciary totally run
amok let's bring in two top attorneys
Harmeet Dillon is a civil rights
attorney in an RNC committee woman from
California and Scott Bolden chair of the
National Bar Association political
action committee I'm lonely in here
without either of you but I'm gonna have
to make to sky initially care dude all
right let's start with you Harmeet on
this citizenship question on the census
up until 1950 we did have that question
on the census and the census changes and
we didn't ask that question but tell us
about the posture of this case and this
particular judge Jessie Furman well
Laura what's happening
here is that these judges are you know
taking these cases and really imposing
their own judicial philosophy and new
standards that are not written into the
law into these cases and you know you
saw the exact same reasoning that Judge
Furman used here which is that Wilbur
Ross who's sort of nominally in charge
of the census in his department had made
some remarks about the reasoning behind
wanting to count citizens that that you
know raised an issue of animus now the
United States Supreme Court recently
ruled that this animus theory which was
used in the Trump travel ban cases is
bogus and not one of the elements and
shouldn't be applied and you know
Clarence Thomas has spoken out on this
issue as well of nationwide injunction
so basically you know this is a
confusion and we have a unelected judge
trying to supersede and impose his
values over what the president gets to
do asking a very reasonable question in
the executive branch and counting that's
the purpose of the census is to count
the people in the country why are you
counting hold on they're counting all
people but there's also a question about
whether you're a citizen or not now
what's the problem with answering the
question well I don't understand them
what is the possible constitutional
argument here
well because it's racially offensive
first of all whether you're a citizen
what well well because it's directed at
P Brown people and black people now
customs matter of course it is it's
directed at all people in the country
you ask a question sweets about
immigrants will you couple that with
directors debates about illegal
immigrants regardless of the supreme
court the church has taken that into
consideration and by the way can I just
say this about cases that case didn't
also wasn't just rested on the
discrimination issues the APA was
violated the court found that despite
the advisory committees as well as staff
ruling against it or recommending the
gifts now Wilbur took on upon his own to
put it in place the case isn't over by
the way they just just got passed a
motion to dismiss so it's not the final
right but to say that Scott uknow you're
saying a question asked of all people is
racist but it has a racially disparate
impact because it's the right to discern
it's absurd we got another case is
Portland out of Portland Oregon it's
involving transgender bathrooms that's
we've heard the transgender bathroom
case and issue for a long time but this
is interesting because it's a parent's
group that's gotten together and said
okay we understand that transgender kids
have rights but we represent families
whose students whose sons and daughters
do not want to share a bathroom for
whatever reason with a transgendered
person of the who's born of the opposite
sex and this judge said you don't get
any privacy rights here and if you have
a problem leave the district
Harmeet is that a is that the kind of
thing that would survive scrutiny I know
that's the Ninth Circuit so anything
goes the Ninth Circuit but that sounds
like a very that's seem kind of like a
harsh ruling on against that parents
group but maybe I'm miss reading it no I
agree with you Laura I think it's harsh
and it's wrong now obviously transgender
students who I think you know may need
you know a number of supports and
medical support are they have rights
obviously but the vast majority of the
students are not transgender and they
have rights too including their privacy
rights and you know people who are
transgender in their youth they may
switch back and forth the specter has
been raised which i think is a real one
of people abusing this transgender
labeling and electing it in order to you
know peep and get into the girls
bathrooms it's not really you know
appropriate to only look at one side or
the other and I can tell you you know in
girls locker rooms we've been there
Laura I mean you know everything is
showing and it's not really something
that you want as a teenager to have a
guy looking at your body I'm sorry to
say the girls looking at my body
it's true but it's not in the face for
the judge to say that the taxpayer the
parents are taxpayers the parents
taxpayers and they have a right to have
their kids educated fairly the parents
have any rights here or just the
transgender you know not compared to the
protected class that the transgendered
student rests in and look at it this way
the judges just following the law
there's no politics here every federal
judge that's looked at this case and
looked at other similar cases around the
country
you check the record they have sided
with the transgender student because
they cannot be discriminated against
simply because they identify with being
a woman or identify with being a guy
it's not Anatomy that counts and they're
in a protected class and so this
decision is based on the law not
politics you may not like it but you got
to live with it
Harmeet last word I mean Anatomy
obviously does count and it is relevant
and the Pratt and the other students are
privacy rights to that it needs to be a
balance not just conjecture give me a
break but Scott you know I know these
fraternity brothers went to college went
on to college these fraternity brothers
are like pranksters that you could see a
situation let's say okay I identify as
this today and then tomorrow there's
these people playing jokes all the time
too so there's a serial issue but then
there are primary you and your guests I
don't think you and your guests take it
seriously the plight of these young
people who identify with a different
agenda it's serious they're in a
protected class read the research of dr.
Pollock you want to know what serious is
alright I read the opinions of both of
these cases and the opinions thank you
it's a medical doctor studied it for
decades
Harmeet I want to congratulate you on
the Ninth Circuit ruling that your case
your civil rights case against those
people who beat up those Trump
supporters you've represented them and
you've done a pretty much pro bono the
whole way the Ninth Circuit said your
case can go forward we're going to be
watching that very closely
argument congratulations on that and
thanks to both of you for being here
tonight